donc tu mets bientôt couteau voilà mais
jusqu'au fond et tu fais glisser voilà
tu forte de plastique pour que ça
décolle toutes la gelée le geste n'a
l'air de rien comme ça mais elle y met
tout son coeur et si elle s'applique
autant c'est parce qu'elle a besoin de
se concentrer un peu plus que les autres
car chloé souffrent d'une déficience
intellectuelle qui la freine dans ses
apprentissages mais elle s'accroche
comme tous ceux qui ont davantage à
prouver la volonté le courage et son
abnégation
hors du cac -
ils sont tout le temps au travail ils
aspirent à travailler parce que
travailler c'est exister
oui je fais travailler mais pas dans un
mail est protégée je vais me battre pour
être dans un milieu ordinaire comme les
autres et la chance de chloé en plus de
son enthousiasme c'est d'aller au lycée
parce qu'à 17 ans l'institut médico
éducatif n'est pas très soit axé sûr
mais surtout parce que ça crée des liens
trop longtemps cloisonné dans un système
spécialisé à part les enfants handicapés
trouve difficilement leur chemin vers
l'intégration asseman ennuyeux est-ce
que vous avez des contraires
dans le doubs depuis la rentrée trois
lycées accueillent qu'une classe
externalisée
après le collège c'était le chaînon
manquant de la transition inclusive
initié dès 2005 et qui réclame que 80%
des enfants soient scolarisés 50% de ce
qu accueil l'adapei leçon un chiffre qui
tombe à moins de 15% pour les 16 20 ans
ce sont d'abord des affronts de l'écho
la république tous les textes le dise
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on y le compte n'y
est pas et c'est pour ça doivent être
repensés parce qu'effectivement la
question de l'accueil des enfants
différents ont lissé n'a pas vraiment
été pensé dans les textes niveau
national depuis des dizaines d'années
donc aujourd'hui on prend conscience que
ces jeunes ont besoin d'accéder aux
lycées et la formation professionnelle
pour qu'entre 20 et 25 ans ce ne soit
pas des chômeurs parce qu'effectivement
l'accès à l'emploi des personnes
handicapées
c'est un fléau
manque de place manque de moyens la
volonté politique affichée dans les
textes est encore timide sur le terrain
il n'empêche
chloé est toute à sa joie d'une vie
presque ordinaire c'est bien lissés ah
oui génial je ne me sens pas handicapé
je me sens comme les autres voilà ça
fait du bien
ah oui oui vous êtes un peu plus
rassurés sur l'avenir de chloé
aujourd'hui ah ben je suis très
optimiste
excusez moi c'est vraiment souci bah oui
voilà c'est pour nous les parents
enfin moi personnellement ça a été une
bouffée d'air une bouffée d'air frais
une bouffée d'air frais parce que le
monde ordinaire pour nous c'est notre
c'est le bout du tunnel
voilà trouver un emploi dans le monde
outre ordinaire c'est notre rayon de
soleil ou alors en plus de chloé mais la
route est encore longue vers une société
bienveillante et plus ouverte à la
différence les travailleurs handicapés
sont deux fois plus touchés par le
chômage
quatre fois plus lorsque le handicap et
intellectuelle